le site de la capitale nationale n'a pas
d'autres choix il faut absolument
recruter à l'international pour avoir du
personnel en ch et celle des originaires
de la tunisie najwa fait partie des
quarante six préposés aux bénéficiaires
qui sont arrivés à québec au cours de
l'été j'ai choisi d'affronter les québec
pour nouveau deux filles de
professionnels et pour améliorer la vie
même la vie d'emma tamir qu'elles sont
encore à la tunisie tous les employés
recrutés à l'international doivent
d'abord bénéficie sans leur famille si
tout une adaptation dans son pays najwa
exercer la profession d'infirmière elle
est maintenant préposés aux
bénéficiaires au centre d'hébergement du
réel j'aime beaucoup cette travail de
proposer aux bénéficiaires et c'est
parce que ces métiers un militaire
j'aime beaucoup j'aime les personnages
et pour que les employés étrangers
n'aime pas seulement leur travail mais
également leur nouvelle vie les suces
met tout en place pour éric lavoie et
son équipe c'est un travail
d'intégration assez ardue on les prépare
beaucoup pendant le processus on les
rend pas comme ça non plus sur les
unités les suisses occupent d'aller
chercher les candidats à l'aéroport de
montréal pour ensuite les amener aux
résidences de l'université laval où ils
sont hébergés au moins un mois les
organismes adoucit les nouveaux
arrivants à trouver les meilleures
épiceries les magasins se créer un
compte bancaire et se loger ces gens là
arrive dans un pays nouveau sont pas
portés à poser des questions donc fait
vraiment de créer un lien de confiance
que ce soit avec nous l'équipe comme un
construite pour toutes à l'international
que ce soit avec les gestionnaires sur
le terrain on a aussi utilisé un préposé
aux bénéficiaires qui a passé par loki
genre de mentor pour répondre à leurs
questions et manger bien bon bout pour
mes collègues vraiment sont
serviables avec moi maintenant najwa n'a
plus qu'un souhait
le sus de capitale nationale les bras
dans ses démarches qui pourraient
prendre quand même quelques années ici
alexandre les radio canada québec